-Well, we're back
from a two-week break,
and I haven't checked in
on the news yet,
so let me just take a look
at these cue cards here.
Russia is reportedly on
the verge of invading Ukraine.
Well, that's not good.
Fox News and
the Republican Party
want to put Hillary Clinton
in jail
for a made-up thing again.
Oh, boy.
Mike Lindell wants to send
pillows to anti-vax truckers
in Canada.
Yikes!
And Donald Trump took classified
documents to Mar-A-Lago
and flushed official White House
records down the toilet.
Alright, well, anyone
could have predicted that part.
[ Laughter ]
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Theme music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let me tell you how hard it is
to be a talk show host.
It's not.
But there are still
some rough moments, okay?
For example, two weeks ago,
we went on break
for the Olympics,
and then a few hours
after we taped our last show,
I'm at home, minding
my own business,
when I see this headline.
"'Masked Singer' judges walk out
after Rudy Giuliani reveal."
And I didn't have a show
to talk about that!
[ Laughter ]
I couldn't talk to my kids
about it,
because, long story short,
they're Trump supporters.
I don't want to get into it.
They're doing it to punish me.
I don't think they actually
believe it.
[ Laughter ]
Point is, I needed my show.
So I called the president
of NBC and said,
"Did you hear
about this Rudy news?"
And he said, "How did you
get this number?"
And then I said, "Can you
cancel the Olympics?"
And he said no, and I said,
"But Rudy was on
'The Masked Singer.'"
And he said, "Seth,
do you really think
this is the last crazy thing
Rudy Giuliani is ever gonna do?"
And I said no.
And he said, "Okay,
don't ever call me again."
But I did find a solution.
I took my desk to Central Park,
and I did a monologue
in the middle of the night
for all the joggers
and squirrels.
[ Laughter ]
I even tried posting
a bunch of jokes
on Donald Trump's new Twitter
rip-off called Truth Social,
which apparently
went live last night.
But like lots of people,
I couldn't even log in,
because when it launched,
select users who tried
to create accounts
were repeatedly met
with a red error warning --
"Something went wrong.
Please try again."
Though, by the time you find
yourself signing up
for Donald Trump's
social-media site,
something already went wrong.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm guessing
they'll try again.
If you were first in line
to sign up for Truth Social,
you probably got some
free time on your hands.
"Well, I'm just sitting here
waiting for JFK Jr.
to reappear at the Meadowlands
with Elvis
and the Loch Ness monster to
prove the election was stolen.
I guess I'll try
logging in again."
[ Laughter ]
I really enjoy how vague
the error message is.
"Something went wrong,"
like even they don't know
what the problem is.
Usually you get an error code
or something,
but Trump's site just gives you
a shrug emoji that says,
"What were you expecting?
This thing's a cluster [Bleep],"
which makes sense because
the guy in charge of the site
is former GOP Congressman
Devin Nunes.
Remember him?
The guy who always looks
like the valet
who forgot where your car was,
or what cars even were.
He said on Fox News
this weekend,
he was hoping the site
would be fully functional
by the end of next month.
- This week, we'll begin
to roll out people
on the Apple App Store.
That's gonna be awesome
because we're gonna get
so many more people that are
gonna be on the platform.
And then, look, our goal is --
and I think
we're gonna hit it --
I think, by the end of March,
we're gonna be
fully operational,
at least within
the United States.
-By the end of March?
This is the digital age.
Everything is measured
in nanoseconds,
and you're moving at the speed
of Civil War letters home.
[ Laughter ]
So, anyway, I was too late
for the Rudy news
and I couldn't post
about it on Trump's site.
But unfortunately, there are
plenty of other
Trump-adjacent pro-coup weirdos
up to their usual weirdness.
Just to give you an idea of how
insane the world is right now,
here's a real headline
I came across the other day.
"MyPillow CEO Mike Lindell
and '10,000 pillows'
blocked from joining
Ottawa protest."
So, Lindell wanted to show
his support for the convoy
of anti-vax truckers
paralyzing Ottawa
by sending them pillows,
but he was blocked
by the Canadian government,
which he explained
on far-right TV channel Newsmax,
from what to me
looks suspiciously
like a fake private plane.
-Tell me what happened
today at the border.
Did you get the --
did you get the pillows in?
-No, we've got a --
we got a new permit.
We got a permit.
I've left there.
I'm not up there now.
I'm actually coming
from another state.
I have to go to another state.
My trucker's there.
He's gonna cross --
gonna try tomorrow morning.
They made us get another permit,
a different -- another permit.
I don't know.
Regulations, red tape.
We're gonna try again
tomorrow morning,
and we're gonna
head into Ottawa.
-I can't believe we're living
in a time
with our very own
Wile E. Coyote.
[As Lindell] we're gonna send
10,000 pillows to Ottawa,
and then I'm gonna
tie myself to a rocket
and shoot myself
across the border.
[Normal voice] Also, why are you
so vague about your location?
"I'm coming from another state
to another state"?
Are you a fugitive?
Did you get put on the FBI's
"least wanted" list?
And let's take a look
at that background again.
I mean, that's got to be fake.
It's like a Zoom background
or a TV set
he has constructed
in his living room
so he can make it look like
he's on a private plane,
or it's a real private plane
that doesn't actually fly
and he just has it parked on
the street outside his house.
And I will say, Lindell
looks less like a guy
who sells pillows
and more like a guy
who sells grounded
private planes
for the purposes of
impressing people on Zoom calls.
[As Lindell] Hey, check out
my new product,
Hot Tub Slices!
It comes with a champagne flute
and two professional models.
[Normal voice] Hot Tub Slices.
We came back hot.
[ Laughter ]
Take two weeks off,
you let the brain rest,
and you come back
with Hot Tub Slices.
[ Laughter ]
So, things are tense
everywhere right now.
As we speak, hundreds of
thousands of Russian troops
are amassed
on the Ukrainian border
amid warnings of
an imminent invasion by Russia.
Now, I'm
no foreign-policy expert,
but my personal opinion
is a war would be catastrophic
and the world should do
everything in its power
to prevent one, which is
why I'm glad world leaders
keep insisting diplomacy
is still an option,
including the possibility of a
summit between Biden and Putin.
-Overnight, president Biden
agreed in principle
to meet with the Russian
leader, Vladimir Putin.
This was in response
to a proposal
from the French President,
Emmanuel Macron.
Unclear how real
of a possibility this is.
The White House says, in theory,
the president would do it,
but only if Putin holds off
on invading Ukraine.
-Fine, go for it.
Anything to stop a war.
Let Biden meet with Putin
and put him to sleep
with stories about
the mean streets of Scranton
and the Acela schedule
for the Eastern seaboard.
It's still better
than the summit Trump did
where he screamed at reporters
about insane conspiracy theories
and held up a soccer ball
he got from Putin
like a kid on Christmas
who was expecting a PS5.
"This isn't what I meant when
I said I wanted to play FIFA!"
I mean, maybe Biden can give
the soccer ball back to Putin.
[As Biden] "Sorry,
it's a little deflated.
Trump sat on it.
He thought it was an egg
and treated it like
a Horton situation."
[Normal voice]
Obviously, world leaders
must do everything possible
to de-escalate
and pursue diplomacy.
And yet some Republicans
and right-wing pundits
have claimed the crisis
is actually just a manufactured
distraction by Democrats
to divert attention from,
among other things,
Hillary Clinton,
who has once again
become an obsession for them
for reasons
that, unsurprisingly,
are total bull[bleep].
-Is it all just a ruse?
The administration hitting
the panic button on Russia.
I questioned whether or not
the whole thing was a ruse,
with Jake Sullivan coming out
so hysterical over the weekend,
telling us to get out of Ukraine
and that Russia
is gonna invade today.
Obviously, in retrospect,
he was trying to change
the conversation
from Hillary Clinton
and her bad behavior --
-Uh, Maria?
-And her dirty tricks
against Donald Trump.
-Maria.
-They were spying on Trump,
as a candidate
and as the president
of the United States,
from the White House?
Why is this not the biggest
story of the year?
-This is the biggest scandal --
spying scandal -- ever.
-What you're talking about
is further than Watergate.
-I think this is far worse
than Watergate, quite frankly.
-Hillary Clinton hired people
who hacked into Trump's home
and office computers, before
and during his presidency,
and planted evidence
that he colluded with Russia.
Yeah, you heard that right.
-Yeah, we heard that right.
You just said it wrong.
Because none of it is true.
Disentangling the web of lies
here is nearly impossible.
Basically, Fox News inaccurately
described a claim
that had been cherry-picked
from a court filing
by a special counsel
assigned by former
attorney general Bill Barr
to investigate the origins
of the Russia investigation,
and then they lied about
that filing to the point
where the special counsel
himself, John Durham,
distanced himself
from the Fox News freakout.
If you ask them to explain
what was actually in the filing,
they'd probably say...
-I don't know.
Regulations, red tape.
[ Laughter ]
-But suffice it to say,
Hillary Clinton did not hack
into Trump's campaign or
spy on Trump's White House,
and she certainly
didn't plant evidence.
For one thing, why would you
have to plant evidence on a guy
who screams evidence
into TV cameras all the time?
That would be like the cops
planting a bag of cocaine
at a meth lab.
They're making it sound like
Hillary Clinton
was in a van
outside Trump Tower,
hacking into the mainframe
"Ocean's Eleven"-style.
"I'm into the Trump mainframe!"
The password was just 'password'
spelled wrong."
[ Laughter ]
Also, you think Hillary Clinton
was capable
of hacking Donald Trump
and digitally spying on him?
Do I need to remind you how bad
she was with technology?
-I don't know
who created Pokémon Go.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm trying to figure out
how we get them
to have Pokémon Go To the Polls.
-Yeah, that person
hacked Trump's campaign
and planted evidence.
Sounds like my mom
drunkenly asking me
how to use FaceTime
on my tablet.
"So, it's called an iPad.
Does that mean
you need an iPen?
Do not take away
my gin and tonic!"
I mean, my God, it's been years,
and they're still obsessed
with Hillary.
I'm gonna tell you
what my therapist told me
about the Rudy Giuliani
"Masked Singer" news.
"Let it go."
[ Laughter ]
And yet I just can't quit you,
you goofy bastard.
[ Laughter ]
Of course, if anything,
it was Trump who was
tampering with evidence.
As we now know,
he reportedly had a habit
of flushing papers
down White House toilets --
so, you know,
Happy Presidents' Day --
and that some
of the White House --
some of the White House
documents
that Donald Trump improperly
took to his Mar-a-Lago residence
were clearly marked
as classified,
including documents
at the top-secret level.
Trump probably let the guests
flip through them
for an extra fee
when they booked their stays.
"Okay, so the breakfast buffet
is 100 dollars extra.
There's also a day pass
to the swimming pool
and spa
that costs 200 dollars.
And for 300 dollars,
you can peruse a classified
Pentagon document
that confirms
the existence of aliens
walking among us in the form
of Midwestern pillow salesmen."
[ Laughter ]
"So, just the spa?
Okay, just the spa."
The right keeps ginning up
manufactured outrages
about their favorite targets
because they don't have anything
serious to talk about.
They're too busy
dismantling democracy,
sending pillows
to Canadian truckers,
and going on
"The Masked Singer,"
which if you ask me, is...
-Far worse than Watergate,
quite frankly.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help now
more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.